many of you may like this show you come
here there's around 12,500 or so of you
and we love that you come to this show
yes we do but YouTube has been
increasingly shutting down content
creators and this is started over the
past few years and as I've predicted and
many of us are predicted what we think
is happening YouTube wants to completely
get rid of this they completely want to
get rid of the independent homegrown
small business media outfit now there
are a lot of people who say really dumb
things and they were the first to go and
I still think it's wrong so I believe in
free speech even for people who aren't
smart it's kind of weird that these
people believe that if you're not smart
enough you're not allowed to speak but
that's what they're doing well it's
slowly getting worse and worse so we
just saw two major complete shutdowns on
YouTube and it's kind of worrying let's
let's let's start with Arielle Scarcella
yes I'll start with what I think it's
just these are the two people we know
right you know it means oh I know tons
of other channels I've seen them
although if it seven of these two like I
can only imagine the amount that is
across the board it's a lot oh go ahead
so here's what's been happening over the
past several years they've been slowly
starting with D modernisations mm-hmm
just you know saying oh no this video is
no good this to be oh is no good and
they're they've they've started a hard
manual review of every single channel
removing people from the partner program
which means you can't make money anymore
you're out that means if you don't make
money they don't recommend your content
because YouTube prioritizes content with
ads in it because they want to make
money yeah so there's some good news for
the high profile youtubers who have
already broke through you're gonna get
more money because these these other
creators are being purged that means the
available ad space is going down I think
I know why they're doing this is a
couple reasons and one of them is ad
space we're late it's supply and demand
but let's take a look at what happened
first we have this tweet from Arielle
Scarcella she was a guest on this show
last month or so and this is a tweet
from January 2018 she said over the past
year YouTube has been killing ads on
most around 79% of my videos if you'd
like to help fund my LGBTQ educational
content please donate to her patreon
there are tons of great rewards and
Skype calls from me well shortly after
appearing on this show she tweeted this
is from a couple days ago I didn't want
to post as publicly but YouTube creators
has deemed monetized my entire channel
for the past three
if you uh if you appreciate my content
please support my work through patreon
if you can't afford it a few dollars
goes a long way this is an email she
received it says during a recent review
our team of policy specialists carefully
looked over the videos you've uploaded
to your channel Arielle Scarcella we
found that a significant portion of your
channel is not in line with our YouTube
Partner Program policies as of today
your channel is not eligible to monetize
and you will not have access to
monetization tools and features please
go to your monetization page to read
more about the specific policy our
specialists flagged now this seems to be
YouTube's escalating their enforcement
because Arielle talks about adults you
know stuff yeah you know sexuality
relationships and things like that but
it was it was okay for the longest time
the media these people that are compete
with YouTube competes with it on like
them then start writing all these fake
all this fake news all these smears that
are just not true algorithmically you
know proven false
researchers from Berkeley even you know
in Berkeley super progressive proved
that the rabbit holes narrative is just
all not true but this is part of what
YouTube is doing to purge creators so
the rules are getting stricter they're
retro actively giving people guideline
strikes which brings me now to one of
the more worrying D monetization 's cuz
look Arial and my opinion shouldn't have
been d monetized they should they should
have they should have said the specific
content we don't want you know it's it's
I get it I'll also point out YouTube has
no obligation to be your ad sales
manager right if nobody wants to watch
your content you it's not YouTube's job
to mark it for you and sell your ads but
so so again I don't think it's fair that
she was banned but she did talk about
the old stuff now Luke on the other hand
talks about news and this is what Luke
tweeted this is this is just from a
couple hours ago just just had YouTube
totally take away my income and now my
entire channel is D monetized why
YouTube craters this is how I survive
why do this now especially during these
difficult times thank you to everyone
who helps here you want to I this so
egregious in my opinion of all of the
times YouTube could destroy someone's
business they're doing at a time when
the economy is already under massive
strain and the last thing we need is for
someone like Luke to lose his job now
I've taken
some actions to try and mitigate the
potential risk because I don't think I'm
safe
how long until YouTube comes and you
know gives the banhammer to me or
anybody else right you know Luke said
there was no specific video or violation
no strikes nothing how the hell am I
supposed to change anything if I don't
know what to change and my livelihood is
dependent on this this is cruel YouTube
creators yep it doesn't matter they
don't care
meanwhile Facebook is running ads of
Chinese state propaganda blaming Trump
for Kovan 19 YouTube will run overt fake
news from mainstream media that just
says you know Trump has been people will
fall for it will go insane and then a
week later turns out Trump was right
right so the example I used in the just
a few minutes ago
I did a video on my second channel about
the Wuhan CDC lab near the the the wet
market
The Washington Post wrote and got a
quote from a Rutgers professor saying
that there were security risks and that
there had been breaches before and we
should consider the possibility
it's basically they were saying we don't
know for sure we do think the most
likely is natural occurrence but it may
have been a breach from up from a lab
YouTube do you monetize that video
because they have told me I'm not
allowed to say the virus may have
originated in a lab even though the
mainstream media says it so this system
can't function but I'll tell you what I
thought what I think they're doing when
you have YouTube with I think there was
like a couple was like a hundred million
channels and most of them don't produce
anything you have essentially infinite
supply minimal demand so what ends up
happening is when a company like Pepsi
wants to run ads they're like I can just
sell an ad for a penny or I can buy an
ad for a penny because there's so much
content mm-hmm that the demand is the
supply is infinite you know it's like
what am I worried about how can YouTube
artificially suppress the supply so that
Pepsi is forced to pay two cents three
cents four cents five cents or more ad
rates are really really low on YouTube
which made it hard for them to attract
high profile and high budget projects
I'll tell you what man the amount of
money that it cost me on YouTube to make
a hot like a really nice beautiful
documentary is a fraction of the cost it
would be for any other production
honey okay so like vice for instance
would spend $50,000 in a ten minute
segment I could do it for a couple grand
but what ends up happening is when you
get people consistent constantly cutting
costs and making low quality content
then advertisers don't wanna be
associated with it yeah you have a
massive supply of cheap content that's
not worth anything and YouTube can't
make money
so YouTube finds an excuse who
everyone's complaining about politics
let's start purging everybody that way
we can force all of these companies to
spend more on digital ads on YouTube
because it is valuable to a certain
degree that will drive up the amount of
money the youtubers get and then they'll
increase their production quality so I
wonder if the actual reason these people
are being purged is because their
production quality was too low or they
didn't have the following that Luke at
622 has 622 thousand subscribers yeah
but where was his videos I don't really
look at his YouTube channel but was it
were they popular and were they like ad
were they advertised like were they able
to be you know advertised in a sense
like you know you said Pepsi as an
example so wouldn't Pepsi want to be
advertised on I don't know drinking this
stuff I guess yeah people drink Pepsi
while they're relaxing whatever but like
you know aren't ads like kind of catered
to the video no not always but yeah like
my political stuff my OCD political
stuff political ads are gone right now
right yes like the moral landscape is
wiped out you know there isn't any this
is crazy so so I'll tell you too from
you know a business standpoint ad
revenue is down down down like bad down
for everybody and it's going down every
single day media companies are laying
people off we're seeing a lot of
companies die to do layoffs or pay cuts
CEOs get their salaries but yeah even
for us ad revenue is dropping
substantially now because I am on my
main channel do politics like ad revenue
dropped off to a ridiculous degree more
than 50%
it's like overnight it's like whoa all
of a sudden gone yeah that's why I've
done a few more sponsored spots but
what's what's what's worrying is you
know I can't I can't say exactly why
they purge Luke but right now of all the
times to do it
when they started D monetizing my
content they were they were d monetizing
everything coronavirus related YouTube
is not a good place to run a business
absolutely not
there's a good opportunity because they
mark it for you that's really what it's
all about yeah but you said it yourself
they don't have any obligation to put
ads on your channel right right so so
here's the problem
YouTube has taken the entire industry
the ad agency mm-hmm the marketing
company and the hosting provider put
them all together which is destroyed all
the competition they've incentivized
everyone to come to their platform and
spend years building the stuff up Luke's
been producing on YouTube for like I
mean how long has it been 15 years some
ridiculous number like yeah so 13 or so
years he's because he's been on YouTube
since it started
cuz he's always been like you know
alternate media alternative median all
the stuff so they tell you all these
things and then without breaking the
rules without breaking any contracts
they destroy your business I'll put it
this way here's how I've always wanted
people imagine if you found a building
in your town and you're like this
building looks great and you went to the
bank
you bought it put everything together
paid your taxes and then one day you're
the local town comes in and says the
first thing we're gonna do is physically
relocate your business out of downtown
40 miles away from the city you'd be
like whoa but then no one will ever come
in to buy you know my cookies that I'm
making yeah that's what YouTube did
first do you ranking your content so
that no one can find it and then they
argue oh but people could still go by if
they want to yeah but are they gonna
look for it right and they remove you
from search now you can't Google search
my channels nope Tim Casson timkez news
not in Google yeah that's that's why
another reason why I'm like you got it
you got it you know change things up now
what they're straight up doing is
imagine you bought a building and they
said you're gonna be good build your
business here all your customers come in
build up the area and then they come in
and just crush your building destroy it
outright without warning without
breaking any contracts you didn't break
any rules so like you kind of touch
something a little bit earlier do you
think it's because YouTube is losing the
ad revenue so they're purging a lot of
people to make the ads worth more so
then they'll just make more money yep
right so it's I think it's a combination
of factors
yeah YouTube is the comp and the media
compete with each other to a to a
certain degree right CBS and Fox and CNN
they're all
you tube they use it YouTube wants to
attract high profile high production
quality shows they do like so my main
channel it's like a browser window with
my face in the corner right I can't
imagine they like that right now this is
different this is multi camera lights
set design and everything so production
quality has gone up Luke was doing and I
mean I mean no disrespect Luke had a
lower production quality okay yeah add
like you know a grainy err camera but he
was doing similar things to what I was
doing with your face on the court that's
why I'm saying I don't know how long I
am for this world yeah this show I think
they might like because it's like a live
show with multiple cameras but we're
still not like the daily show where you
do everything pre-scripted and it's all
this fake stuff or whatever true but I
think that's an excuse they they want to
get higher higher higher quality content
which requires better paying ads they
want Hollywood to come to you know
YouTube and use them as a platform yeah
they want to be Netflix right and they
can't so long as they have people on
YouTube screaming about the Illuminati
and lizard people so I do think they
like me the the theory that I've had for
a long time as to why I think YouTube
tolerates me is that there's a certain
amount of conservatives who do watch me
mm-hmm but I'm not over overtly
conservative so I don't you know so
they're people like you know steven
crowder for instance they takeaways
monetization they say you say naughty
words boom you can't make money for me
it's like more moderate okay so they
they don't want to lose any of their
users and if they start banning everyone
on the right they'll lose all their
users and so I we did a serve and I
think it was something like you know 17
to like 25 percent of the people who
watch me identified as conservative okay
so I think what YouTube sees is here's a
guy who if we ban the Conservatives
they'll stay around to watch him so we
won't lose them so keep him around they
don't like me they don't like what I say
but it's safe for the brand's right that
means that the conservatives who they
think you know push the boundary they
don't like they can get rid of and then
hope that I might pick up some of these
you know people who get left behind I
guess that works both ways - you're
talking about one side and the same goes
for the other side right they don't they
don't care about the far left oh no
lunatics they don't for the most part
they just ignore it okay so you actually
have channels that have have have you
know told people how to commit crimes
and stuff
and they don't care they don't care yeah
yeah they don't care it's it's that
that's that's exactly how it goes I mean
you look at what happened with Trump on
Twitter okay
Joe Biden launched his campaign by
mismatching statements from Trump to lie
it's called the the very fine people
hoax okay right so yeah I won't get into
much detail but anyway anyway Joe Biden
makes ads where he takes one sentence
another Senate smash them together and
Twitter heads fine
Trump shows one clip of something Joe
Biden actually said but it was the rest
of his sentence was cut and they flag it
as manipulated so then Joe Biden comes
out with another video that mish-mash
his words from Trump to make sentences
Trump never said serious let's what he
did Wow yeah like he took a word from
Trump crota virus and then took hoax and
mashed him together
Trump never said it but now people
believe he did Wow and Twitter refused
to take it down or flag it so then the
Trump campaign did the same thing to
Biden and that didn't do anything either
but the the one-directional nature of
how this stuff works is very very
obvious I will add it's no coincidence
in my opinion that only a couple weeks
after Arielle Scarcella comes out
condemning the far-left they stripped
her from the partner program to hit
point yep that's a good point
it was almost immediately after she said
that she was coming out as more as more
conservative or something or as leaving
the left I think she said it was right
because they've gone nuts then what
happens a couple weeks later she's out
but we're no more money wouldn't that be
make her more in tune with like your
channel because the Conservatives are on
the right like she's saying she's
leaving the left yep she's coming more
towards the center so wouldn't that I
mean you know it just doesn't make sense
to me like why would she yet she would
abate yeah she would have been one of
them safe video-makers well she does
talk about adult stuff yes okay like
adult relationship things yeah I think
that was a line for them to you okay I
guess and now she's she's starting to
dance around on the leaving the left
stuff which the media has me
relentlessly relies and so I think
there's like probably a risk assessment
score or something maybe where they're
like Oh add these factors together
the problem with Luke is that Luke's got
a long standing history on YouTube so
you go back to what's Luke supposed to
do
delete ten years of videos they could go
back to ten years and find everybody
who's ever done find one of they don't
like and ban him for it yeah so that's
that's a serious conversation people on
YouTube have had is do we just delete
every video a week later and then upload
that to an archive website for people to
watch if they want to watch it I don't
know maybe I feel like you're the expert
here I don't know you know you you you
look at Family Guy and I question why it
is that Family Guy has a character that
is a Jewish stereotype that in every
possible most demeaning way it mocks him
for being Jewish yeah we just were
watching I think it was uh it was Family
Guy and Stewie and Brian have a
conversation about trans people mm-hmm
and they asked it was like really
offensive
hey but that's fine on every platform on
it's it's fine on YouTube it's fine a
Netflix and Hulu like that scene that's
scene yeah was it was Stewie and Brian
sitting there questioning what trans
people are like downstairs and like a
bunch of other really offensive things
you see how I have to frame the frets
say these things on usually yeah they
well this stream will get shut off like
people don't realize this there have
been people who have been streaming and
and I'll tell you what it's not
necessarily the same thing but David
Pakman progressive youtuber I think it's
fair to say he's progressive liberal he
was he was streaming the debates and
they disabled a stream because he was
commenting on footage that was publicly
available in broadcast it's happened to
a ton of people even c-span has been
flagged so they're really trying to shut
down non mainstream content if you are a
non mainstream personality and you are
commenting on you know the live Democrat
debates they will ban you outright they
ban you from live-streaming so we got to
be careful but but it's crazy that we
live in this world where I have to abide
by a two-week delay that YouTube because
of you so let me restart over the
Washington Post will say hey maybe it
started in the lab YouTube says don't
you say it don't you say it until the
media says it and I'm like what the
media said it right no like and then two
weeks later somewhat YouTube finally
figures out they're saying it says okay
now you can say it Voldemort the the
political guy who the CIA is named I
can't say hey I was told by YouTube I
would be allowed to say his name
the moment it became a in the public
debate and said by politicians and by
the media okay and it was said numerous
times on Fox News and it was said by a
couple different politicians and then
when I asked I was like okay are we good
now they said no they even deleted a
video of a senator speaking on the
Senate floor saying his name Wow
that's how insane YouTube is he has
gotten so anyway I can write this one up
because I think we've gone for a while
with discussion I'll tell you this yeah
I would not be surprised if in the next
six months considering an election year
I don't know it'll happen but I would be
surprised if my channels are purged all
of them outright even this one so who
knows wonderful for now everything seems
to be going okay yeah okay thank you
everybody
no but for real appreciate you're one of
one of the reasons for wanting to do
this show was like I work all day every
day and I'm seeing this happening and
I'm like they've blacklisted my channels
yeah did not yet mm-hmm I'm gonna make a
new channel and we're into something
different you know and we're gonna try
and and and it doesn't matter because
when tympole gets banned all of Tim
Poole is banned let's start a new
channel and bring on a soy kind of so I
browse so it kind of yeah Chatham and
Here I am whoa
we'll see what happens you know for now
it's it's not even it's it's scary to
see them hitting you know Ariel and Luke
they're both verified Twitter users like
very different right yeah yeah so I how
do you even how do you even figure out
why they got removed
there's no commonality almost no idea so
I don't I you know I don't know if I'm
safe or not but I but I can say even
right now I'm not even super worried
yeah right now I am but with ad revenue
tanking because of you know kovat and
all that stuff yeah I'm not even sure
how much it matters cuz you know I've
been doing the sponsor spots and it
suffice to say that that made up for a
decent amount of loss it the sponsor
spots I've done have covered the losses
and and and done me a little bit better
but if I didn't do them I'd be down
substantially so for now with the goal
being to expand and survive like people
don't understand how it works or the
business they think that if you make
good money then you're good forever but
look at all these big corporations that
are like we have one month of operating
costs right it's not
business no it's not we'll see what
happens everybody